how many days can you survive without
any water three
right then i've heard about dry fasting
dry fasting
don't do it it's a bad idea people
eating and drinking nothing for three
four even five days while some say it's
nothing but threatening oh this is a
dangerous diet fad
the anecdotal evidence claims insane
health benefits
so of course i had to try it out i
committed to 72 hours taking
measurements and pictures before and
after it my buddy aaron would join me
for the first 48 hours and to make it
extra challenging and fun me and my
roommates decided to see if we could
tempt each other to break out fast and
test our discipline
here we go it's 11. my last coconut
water
[Music]
another lasted for 72 hours it's one
past 11 there's a little bit left
i know i cannot have it i'm thirsty
already
no i'm doing or i'm attempting to do
a hard dry fast which means no contact
with water which means i can't
brush my teeth i cannot wash my hands
and
i cannot shower it's twice as [ __ ]
hard as when you do
a soft dry fast where you can still
shower because your body becomes like a
sponge
and will hydrate itself so not showering
will
make this even more challenging i was
just about to grab these banana peels
and put them into the bin but then i
realized
wait a minute i won't be able to wash my
hands after that oh [ __ ] i forgot to
brush my teeth as well
you go for a piss and you can't even
wash your hands it just feels very
very wrong i have a pretty dry mouth
i'm pretty thirsty i'm getting nauseous
that time's ten what is that true seven
hours
72 hours yes my brain isn't even working
properly
i've prepared a little gift for
aaron a water tasting kid is he going to
be able to resist
we'll see yo
hey how's your muscles doing i'm working
on it there's a pretty good package
that arrived i don't know if it's for
you how are you going with the dry fast
thirsty what about you yes incredible
man i'm
you know i feel nothing i'm drinking a
pizza
already cool i'll see you love it
[Music]
hey i don't want to open this lay up to
your box
what it's not it's not wait it says your
name on it this is freshly sealed from
amazon it's
pretty obvious oh oh a water tasting
collection how inconvenient to get that
now
what do you want to do with this water
well i don't know it's not mine
[Music]
but this one's premium this one's tastes
really good do you wanna
open it open it i know you want it
do you smell it just take one sip here
and it's fine
i'm just gonna keep this here so
whenever you feel like it just you know
just just grab it hopefully my attempts
wouldn't eventually backfire
it's day two i didn't sleep well i've
got sweaty palms starting to
reek i feel my heart rate is elevated my
mind feels tired but my body feels
very awake and restless which is a weird
combination all right let's weigh in and
see what the measurements say
so this is obviously a very
controversial topic if you
listen to the doctors and the mainstream
advice
it's you're gonna die after three days
of not drinking you shouldn't do it it's
just bad
and there's no benefit from it but then
you have all the evidence of people that
tried it
claims that almost seemed too good to be
true and then also the narrative
of it being natural and our bodies were
made
to get through that a lot of people
still think that you shouldn't eat fat
that's that's gonna make you fat
even smoking used to be recommended by
doctors and that's why i'm always
willing to try out new things that
make sense logically even if the
mainstream hadn't caught up to it yet
and the mainstream advice has killed
far more people than people like this
that just try something new
but i'm open minded to the idea of it
being bad or good
i just want to try it out and that's the
only way to know
it's been 24 hours so i'm in a third of
the way i'm feeling all right
she's trying to tempt me but it's not
working bake some banana bread to tempt
them
the aroma will start lofting up into
their rooms
you wouldn't like the banana bread
making banana bread it's so good
so leon is trying to get his wet laundry
out of the washing machine to put into
the dryer
[Applause]
ah easy so i was just
tanning this is
hey i'd really like to share this video
with aaron this woman gulping the water
airdrop do you mind if i just leave this
stuff
just imagine it flowing in your mouth
your antics don't work on me
i've got to make sure that all these
pranks on aaron don't backfire on me
and i end up suffering more than he is
[Music]
i know my kryptonite aaron's kryptonite
is pizza
i'm drinking a pizza already oh damn
specialty pizzas
ultimate pepperoni he's gonna hate it
[Music]
oh hey what i mean it's very fresh fresh
out of the oven can i give it a bite
i do come on just one bite there and
it's fine this won't break your fast
barely has any calories
i mean if you don't want it just you
know just go back to work and keep
focusing on your work it's fine
also i just wanted to test out my new
fan i put it right here if you don't
mind just get back to work it's fine
what is that
in your mouth is that water coming up
did you put this up no dude the smell is
coming in strong now
this way
[Music]
it's one a.m i thought i could get some
relief but just being
asleep but i can't it's been getting
really hard
it's mind-boggling i've only done half
of it
felt like an eternity already why am i
doing this
i just hope i don't die overnight
uh good morning i don't know how i
survived this night but
i feel horrible uh i also don't know why
i'm the skeleton in my bed
so i slept maybe four to five hours i
feel
very bad my mouth is so dry and i just
need to get by
[Music]
hey tegan why do you have to do the
dishes now
i'm meditating to forget about water
this is how much time i have left aaron
had finished his 48 hours and decided to
go another 12 hours without food
it's gonna feel so good man and it's
gonna feel so bad for me
i'm the only one now going without water
tomorrow
oh man i'm so jealous there we go
ah damn i can feel myself hydrating just
remember
man it's satisfying yeah yeah
man i'm actually really close to just
running over and grabbing that off of
here i'm having doubts whether i can
pull this off when it comes to my
discipline yes i can when it comes to my
body
i'm not sure i noticed that when i stand
up
too quickly then i can get very very
dizzy
if i get to the point where i faint i
will have to stop it i bet
tonight is going to be very very rough
and tomorrow i don't want to know how
i'm going to feel
another 18 hours to go the time is going
past
so slow
18 hours do you know how long that is
but looking at how long i've been
fasting
54 hours no drinking not a single sip
damn make it to 72 hours
and don't pass the [ __ ] out
no contact with water the water balloons
i think is cool just throw it at him
it absorbs even the water that touches
your skin
because he can't get wet right like
he'll have to catch it or
dodge it
oh
15 minutes for him i'm seriously
considering just going upstairs now and
not watching it this is the
12 hours left for me
[Music]
time to drop the beat
there it is the final product the moment
has come
ah how's it
what's it like on the other side it's
okay to cry it's so
satisfying is it damn yeah and now all i
have to do is
get through the night don't faint and
then tomorrow morning you got it man
just to go finish it off man
finish this straw all right
last night and tomorrow morning i will
have made it
it is so funny how the mind tries to
trick you into
giving in into giving up have you ever
had a crush on someone where you
couldn't stop obsessing about them
and fantasizing about being with them
watermelon
wanna hug a watermelon go on a date with
a watermelon i want to have a wild
intimate
baby it's 3 30 a.m now
still haven't slept at least i'm not
thinking about what about mouth
at least i'm not thinking about
watermeloning i can't talk
i think about oranges now wish me luck
[Music]
it's the final morning and i slept four
hours i have fasted for 70 hours
no water no food no getting in touch
with any water
and i've only got two hours left until i
can't yeah
this is the last two hours no
i'm getting on my knees i'll do anything
you want i might actually cry
i'm so proud of myself i can't believe
that i've gone
three entire days and nights without any
food without any water without getting
in touch with any water
i'll do the final weigh-in and reveal
the final numbers
to show how my body used its internal
resources to survive this
i will wash my hands like they've never
been washed before
i'll have the most satisfying sips of
liquid of my entire life
i'll prepare the most delicious meal my
taste buds have yet to experience
i'll take the most epic shower in human
history
and i'll eat a [ __ ] watermelon
through this i learned that the simplest
things like water and food
are actually a luxury you can't you're
the one
and that when people are passionately
arguing whether something is good about
you
the only way to really find out is to
try it for yourself
also really important for the next video
i filmed the most epic date i've ever
been on it's a follow-up from the video
where i put myself on a billboard to get
dates if you haven't seen it yet then
make sure you check it out right now
thanks for coming along and creating
another memory with me